Welcome to our video on best digital
marketing Trends 2024 in this session we
will explore the latest trends
strategies and the best practices that
can help you grow your business online
digital marketing is a utilization of
digital channels and Technologies to
effectively reach engage and convert a
specific target audience this includes a
diverse set of strategies including but
not limited to search engine
optimization social media marketing
email marketing content marketing
influencer marketing and various other
approaches digital marketing is not only
a powerful way to connect with your
customers but also a proven way to
improve your brand value and revenue as
per Gartner report digital marketing
strategy is what sets best-in-class
performance apart from the rest the
report also identified 45 brands that
has achieved genius status in 2023 by
excelling in digital performance
maturity and investment so now let's
have a look at some of the benefits of
digital marketing first it enables you
to connect with a broad and varied
audience worldwide across the globe with
74% marketers agreeing with the
customers are placing increased value on
digital experiences then it enables you
to measure and optimize your campaigns
in real time using data and analytics to
track your performance and Roi next is
it empowers you to create personalized
and relevant content and messages for
your audience using Ai and storytelling
to enhance customer experience and
loyalty next one it helps you Leverage
The Power of social media and influencer
marketing using platforms like Tik Tok
Instagram and YouTube to create a viral
and engaging content for your brand also
if you are interested in advancing your
career consider pero University's
post-graduate program in digital
marketing this comprehensive program
offers certification as a digital
marketer through live Interactive
Learning dive deep into fundamental and
advanced digital marketing strategies
utilizing Harvard Business publishing
cases and Hands-On participation in 20
plus projects access the full spectrum
of digital marketing tools with chat GPT
and AI tools complemented by 35 Plus
dedicated resources all right so this
was about digital marketing and its
benefits now moving on to top digital
marketing Trends to follow in
2024 all right so let's explore how
these Trends are reshaping the marketing
landscape so first on the list is
podcast so podcast are gaining
popularity over blogs especially among
younger audiences they offer convenience
intimacy and engagement that blogs may
not provide additionally podcasts allow
brand to Showcase their personality
expertise and values in more authentic
manner connecting with their audience in
a real and honest way this shift towards
podcast reflects the changing
preferences of consumers particularly
the younger generation who participates
the conversational and immersive nature
of this medium consequently brands are
discovering that podcasts provide an
efficient platform for connecting with
and involving their target audience in a
more personal and significant manner so
this was about podcast now coming to the
next digital marketing trend on the list
which is emphasizing the importance of
branding so branding is more than just
logos and slogans it involves crafting a
unique identity and narrative that
resonates with target audience effective
brandings helps differentiate from
competitors build trust and loyalty and
increases customer lifetime value in
2024 customers are expected to
prioritize brands that demonstrate a
commitment to Society well-being Beyond
just Financial considerations all right
so this was about the importance of
branding next up we have is short form
content so short form content consumed
in under 10 minutes has become a
dominant force in digital landscape this
content type includes videos stories
reals tweets captures attention delivers
value and encourages action a report by
similar web highlights that the average
user spends 95 minutes daily on short
form content like YouTube Tik Tok
Instagram and Snapchat so this was about
short form content this is the trend now
coming to the next Trend which is multi-
region marketing that is US UK India so
the multi- region marketing is about
adapting your marketing strategies to
fit the unique cultures languages
behaviors of different regions by doing
this you can connect with more people
boost your sales and make your customers
happier in 2024 it's crucial to pay
attention to Major digital markets such
as us UK and India because they are not
only large but also growing rapidly
these Geographic areas offer substantial
prospects for business aiming to broaden
their influence and enhance their
achievements customizing your marketing
Endeavors to meet the distinct needs and
preferences of these diverse markets you
can better engage with potential
customers and improve your overall
performance this approach allows you to
speak directly to the people you want to
reach making your marketing more
effective and impactful ultimately
multi-region marketing can help your
business thrive in today's Global
Marketplace all right now coming to the
next Trend that is voice search yes
voice search involves using your voice
to look for things the information
products or services on the internet
using devices such as smartphones and
smart speakers or laptops it's getting
more common and accurate because of
improvements in understanding natural
language and recognizing speech voice
search can be really handy fast and easy
to use especially when people are busy
on the move or have trouble seeing or
moving a report by Juniper research
suggests that add revenue from voice
searches could hit 19 billion by 2024
and that's a very big number so this was
about voice search the next trend on the
list is automated and personalized email
marketing yes so automated and
personalized email marketing involves
using software and data to send
customized email to your subscribers
talking into action their preferences
behavior and actions this approach saves
time time by automating the process of
sending out emails and ensures that the
content is relevant to each recipient
increasing engagement and potentially
leading to more conversions a report by
litmas revealed that 68% marketers
consider email personalization a top
priority for 2024 indicating the growing
importance of this strategy in the
market World by tailoring emails to
individual subscribers businesses can
create more meaningful connections with
their audience leading to higher open
rates click- through rates and
ultimately better results for their
email marketing efforts now moving on to
the next Trend which is AI in marketing
yes AI in marketing refers to the use of
artificial intelligence for various
marketing activities including analyzing
data creating content and segmenting
customers personalizing marketing
strategy optimizing campaigns and
measuring performance by leveraging AI
businesses can improve their efficiency
Effectiveness and creativity in
marketing while also gaining deeper
insights into the customer and
competitors a report by Salesforce
highlights that 57% of marketing leaders
view AI as crucial for delivering
personalized customer experiences this
indicates the growing importance of AI
in helping marketers tailor their
approach to meet the public and specific
needs and preferences of individual
customers ultimately leading to more
meaningful and impactful interactions
imagine you have a fantastic shop in a
busy street but no one seems to notice
it because it's stucked away in a corner
and SEO or search engine optimization is
like putting up bright signs and arrows
that guide people straight to your shop
it helps your website stand out in the
vast online world making it more likely
for people to find and visit it so SEO
is like the friendly guide that ensures
your website gets the attention it
deserves bringing in more visitors and
potential
customers and for doing so a tool is
very crucial and one of the best tool
out there there is SEO powerit so SEO
powerit stand out as the best solution
for all your SEO and digital marketing
requirements it offers four powerful
tools like rank tracker website auditor
ASO spy glass and Link assistant
providing you with a complete toolkit to
boost your search engine rankings unlike
many other SEO software options SEO
powerit offers a onstop shop for
optimizing your online presence and
achieving better visibility on search
engines all right now the question must
arise how do I use SE power suit so for
that we will focus on four things that
is keywords on page SEO back links and
Link building and first we'll have to
focus on keywords for that we will be
navigating to rank tracker all right so
this is our rank tracker we'll double
click on
it so rank tracker is a valuable tool
designed to assist you in discovering
profitable keywords monitoring your own
rankings as well as those of your
competitors and conducting thorough
competitive analysis also it serves as a
comprehensive solution to enhance your
understanding of keyword and overall
market dynamics so first of all we'll
have to create a project over here so
over here we'll have to type the URL of
this website and so I will just type
here
b.com it's an e-commerce site all right
so we will click on next then again
we'll connect on next and here you can
enter the keywords if you want and if
you don't want then you can proceed by
clicking on
next here you can add more search
engines Google Bing Yahoo ask.com I mean
it's your choice if you want to add it
or not I just don't want to add all
these Google and Yahoo are sufficient
then we'll click on
finish all right so our project is
getting ready all right so it is loaded
so first of all we'll start by
understanding the menu bar so the menu
bar is like the control center like of
rank tracker offering a set of drop-
down menus that help you manage your
projects and preferences so let's
understand first so this is file so this
menu handles basic commands relating to
your project such as opening closing and
saving files it's your go to for
managing project files efficiently then
there is preferences as we can see here
in preferences uh you can set up Global
configuration for the application and
customize settings specific to each
project it's like the headquarters of
trailering rank tracker to suit your
needs then there is window so window
this menu provides a list of supported
hot Keys like keyboard shortcuts and
allows you to quickly switch between
different modules or sections within the
application it's all about making
navigation and action more efficient so
you can also learn these shortcuts as
well then there is help so in The Help
menu you can find information about your
rank tracker uh license along with the
links to online help resources if you
ever need guidance or have questions
this is where you can find the
assistance all right then here comes the
project as you can see project this menu
is like a project management Hub it
displays a drop- down list of all the
projects currently open in rank tracker
allowing you to easily switch between
them so only one project is there so it
is showing that only now the next one is
new so the new Option lets you create a
fresh project and then open is there use
this option to load an existing project
from your hard drive or cloud storage
then save we all know save your open
projects with this command you can do
that then close this option allows you
to exit then as we can see check all so
check all rankings in all the open
projects simultaneously with this
command it steam lines the process of
gathering information across your
various projects then you can also login
like found in the SEO pow Cloud login
area this is where you log to access
Cloud related features all right so this
was about the menu bar now coming to the
sidebar so quickly let's understand this
one so first of all there is the
dashboard as you can see project
dashboard this is your project Central
Hub it provides a visual summary of key
statistics related to your organic
traffic ranking progress and how well
your competitors are doing it serves as
a quick gate to all main project
sections then there is rank tracking for
in this module you will find a list of
keywords you're targeting it shows their
ranking history traffic statistics
keyword efficiency index Kei keyword
difficulty and other essential data that
you may need to update regularly so it
is like that all right now as you can
see next is keyword research so here it
is so here you can explore new keyword
ideas using our 20 different tools like
it is in there the module allows you to
analyze and categorize new keywords into
groups and move them to Target keyword
section all right so as we can see these
are that 20 different tools the tools
that we are talking about then there is
Sur analysis that is SCP analysis this
is for in-depth keyword analysis it
provides you detailed analytical report
on websites competing with you for the
same queries then competitors research
this module aables you to research on
competitors based on domain or topic
domain strength it offers overall report
on your website's SEO strength showing
how it evolves over time then there is
reports this module is for generating
and you know delivering reports to your
clients and I think that would be
sufficient so we have already created a
project and while creating a project you
can add seed keywords that you know
describe your business or use the ones
the tool suggest then see where your
website stands for and it helps you
understand how well your site is doing
in search results so the next step would
be analyzing so first of all for
analyzing that first of all we'll have
to go to keyword research you click on
that and then ranking keyword is there
as we can see all right so now here you
can type the name of the competitor and
click search so let's just say I want to
type the name of the competitor the so
store let's say
all right now I'll click on
search make sure the URL is
correct and it might take some time it
is fetching something it is collecting
the keywords and then it will compare
the keyword profiles all right so this
is what it is this is the result and as
we can see keywords and this is organic
traffic this is URL of the sold
store and these are the keywords as we
can see so these are basically the
keywords for which the competitors are
ranking and access their performance we
can you can have the option to
investigate any competitor of your
choice or rely on rank tracker to
recommend the most relevant ones within
your specific Niche now after this you
can explore keywords with various
keyword research methods like keyword
app search console Keyword Planner autoc
complete tools selected searches keyword
combination Etc so as you can see all
these are over here you can have a look
at these and explore these meanwhile we
can explore this keyword sandbox as you
can see keyword sandbox with the help of
this we can filter our keywords which is
the next step all right so this is
keyword
sandbox now we'll utilize the metrics
provided in the mod module to identify
and filter potentially lucrative
keywords eliminating those unlikely to
generate relevant traffic for our
website so factors such as search volume
as we can
see and keyword difficulty and
competition can guide you in selecting
Target keywords effectively so as you
can see these are the search volumes
and this is the competition competition
is high for this
keyword and keyword difficult is also
mentioned
so you can filter out the keywords
according to your choice you can either
select or stop like drag like we can see
so it's your choice you can filter out
the
keywords so whichever you don't want to
you can just click on it and it will be
dragged now your keywords will appear
also in the track keyword so like I have
tracked this one and this one so in
track keywords I I can have a look look
at these all right so this was about it
next we will go to the website auditor
so website auditor ensures your website
is optimized on the page and checks if
it functions well technically and in
terms of content
optimization so we'll open the website
auditor and then we'll type
the website that is
b.com right click
on
finish all right so as you can
see to get a good ranking on search
engines it's important to optimize your
site first of all in terms of both
technology and content we will be using
website auditor for this job but before
that let's have a look at what all
things are there so first of all we'll
explore similarly that we explored in
the previous one so this is the menu bar
and I think we have explored this and
and this is the sidebar it is bit
different from that so let's explore the
sidebar so site structure we have as you
can see this section organizes all the
elements of a website including its
pages and resources it provides like a
visual map of the site along with an
audit dashboard that accesses various Su
factors so as we can see page audit over
here now the page audit will do the page
level analysis so this was the function
of page audit then domain strength is
there so this feature offers
comprehensive report on overall strength
and performance of your website domain
showcasing its growth over time after
that there is reports this module allows
users to generate and share reports with
clients it serves as a tool to
communicate the findings and insights
obtained from the analysis of the site
structure and domain strength so this
was about the sidebar now we can start
with the little demo so so first we have
to create a project that we already
created and wait till the tool crawls
and collects all the pages on your
website so that we have done already now
we'll go to site audit so as you can see
here under site structure site audit now
after visiting site audit we'll address
each technical issue systematically
following the tools recommendations to
eliminate all the
discrepancies so as you can see we are
not able to see any error as you can see
error zero one warning is one
information is one so there is nothing
exactly to be fixed but if there is some
error or something is there then we can
easily do that with the help of this
tool all right so next we can do is
visualization as we can see over here
under site audit you click on that now
to ensure visualization basically is
used to ensure your site is well
structured the tool transforms your
website into a visually intuitive app
once generated you can effortlessly
sport important address like issues
orphan Pages isolated sections redirects
broken links and more so this is what it
is used for on the right side you can
arrange the pages based on the click
depth as we can see click depth internal
page rank page
views so on the right side this is the
right side and if you switch to internal
page link as you can see you'll click on
that you can see how how the internal
link are spreaded like it is bit
different sorting by Page views if you
see it lets you see which pages are
visited and viewed the most and least
but we're not able to figure it out as
of now for that I think we'll be needing
a Google analytics account and we'll
need to log in with that all right so
after reviewing and addressing on page
optimization for the site let's revisit
the keyword you gathered in Rand tracker
like use website auditor keyword map as
we can see keyword map for keyword map
we'll have to go over page audit inside
page audit it is keyword map now this
module automatically identify the pages
most relevant to each keyword
group so the program will take a few
moments to harvest all the data for your
keywords and Pages for further analysis
first of all you'll have to type the
keywords all right let's say
want to
write
joggers
watch
printed
T-shirts
shirts
sliders
and you can write as many as givers you
want
jacket
hoodies
shs all right I think that is
sufficient now you can
also import from CSV so basically uh in
the rank tracker you can also download
and import from CSV or you can import
directly from rank tracker also now we
have wrote the keywords over here now
we'll click on create map now the
program will take few moments to harvest
all data for the keywords and the tool
automatically identifies the pages most
relevant to your keyword group or
specific keyword so this is showing only
one it should at least show five because
website auditor will suggest the top
five most fitting Pages for each keyword
of group
so we must add more keywords I
believe we can add manually or we we can
just have a look at rank tracker also
like hellfire club shirt we can
see can add
that all
right all right so still it is showing
one so after finding a match as you can
see we have find the match just over
over the page and click map as you can
see we'll have to click on this or this
relevant it
is all right
so we'll have to hover over this and
we'll click on map now with the ready G
map ensure your landing page is
optimized for Target keywords now we'll
go to content audit first so here we can
adjust the target settings set the
default search engine for competitor
page and assign a specific one for the
current page so as you can see they are
showing the errors and
warnings so that we can improve on it
and as we just showing make your page
meta description approximately 22 word
long so it is showing how to fix also
basically and if we'll talk about
competitors we can see
Amazon and many other hm hm is there
American Giant Nike so they have used
the keywords they're showing the meta
description it is
showing all right so now coming to the
content
editor so this is content editor
basically what it does is to start
editing an existing page you will need
to choose between the editing modes
first of all as you can see so it might
take some time when you click on that
after doing that it might take like 5 to
10 minutes after it will show this
window now you'll need to choose between
editing modes browser mode is there and
document mode is there so let's just
select browser mode and let's click on
go you can easily you know edit this
site also and properly write an SEO
optimized title so as you can see 33.2%
optimization rate is there it is showing
and other than that we can click on
this and this is showing us manage
mapped keywords manage search engines so
manage search engines so this will
change the default search engine set a
separate search engine for the given
page this can be helpful when optimizing
for creating a regional or local page
and click manage search engines you can
also do that all right so the two top
Fields as we can see this one this one
so these two Fields will let you edit or
enter The Meta title and meta
description
tags and you can see how those fit into
the intersections the recommended number
of characters based on the best SEO
practices so as you can see 311 160 you
can easily edit that and make it SEO
friendly also all your target keywords
will show up in the mapped keywords as
you can see the mapped keyword hood is
so the green here it is green so green
means okay orange if it was orange it
means almost there red as an alarming
for neglecting or stuffing so next to
each keyword as you can see you will see
the actual keyword Count versus
recommended so the recommendations are
customizable simply click on any chip to
manually change the
recommendation so you can do that then
the recommend recommended keywords this
section will list the keywords that have
been extracted from the top ranking
pages of your competitors so you can
also include these as per your
choice and then you can save in an HTML
document from here and and you can reset
from here and save so once finished save
the page and upload it on your website
so now let's just go to back
links now for back links we'll have to
go to SEO spy glass it is a useful tool
for checking backlinks it helps you
gather and analyze your own backlinks as
well as those of your
competitors so it's a good tool so again
we can write the website URL so we will
type
b.com all right now we'll click on
next SE power
suit and we can also change this as per
our
choice let's
say We'll click on so these were the
number of back links so I've wrote
10,000 so it is collecting back links as
of now please wait while seos py glass
collects backlink statistical data and
builds up the project okay so these are
the number of backlinks that this site
has
130,000 domains
9,622 and IPS
8361 all right so these is is the this
is basically the data so search engines
prioritize websites that have backlinks
from reputable domains conversely an
abundance of backlinks from spam sites
can negatively impact your domain's
reputation also considering this it is
advisable to access your existing
backlink profile before embarking on any
efforts to build it further so this
involves examining and evaluating all
the back links already directed to your
site so we are going to do that and SEO
spy glass is one of the best tool for
that so step one find the pages linking
to your site for that to gather all the
back links directed to your site you
need to initiate a new project in SEO
spy class that we already did and now we
can navigate to backlinks
profile and click on
backlinks all right so the tool will
examine its index and identify all the
backlinks providing a variety of useful
metrics essential for further
analysis so as we can see backlink page
domain in link rank link page links back
so all the backlink pages are there it
is also showing
130k back links all right now coming to
the linking domains so in linking
domains module you can quickly switch
between all domains new or lost
ones and additionally set the program to
show all tlds or filter out any specific
one
like
in.org
g.net like
that all right now the anchor texts so
the anchor Texs module will show the
summary wiget with the total number of
unique anchors and anchor diversity
diagram and backlink distribution of
anchor type the workspace will list all
the anchor texts associated with
backlinks in the project alongside
you'll see the states for each anchor
like link type as we can see and number
of back links you can also see
847 and and linking domains Etc also
hovering over any cell in the back links
domains columns you'll see the icon of
expanding the list of URLs to look
through so as you can see these are the
backlink page list of
URLs all
right now let's move on to the referal
traffic and to analyze the traffic your
website is getting through the backlinks
turn to referral traffic module this
this is the referral driv modu under
backr profile this is backlink profile
if you want to analyze your website you
can come here in your S Class once you
click the update traffic Button as we
can see over here update traffic
stats or this also will work no this one
only once you click on this the program
will ask you to connect your Google
analytics account and if you haven't yet
then you can enter it so this is how it
will work so once the account is
connected it will take few moments for
the program to gather the data from
Google analytics or the backlinks in the
project after the task finishes you'll
see the results in the workspace you can
then switch between views linking
domains and backlink pages so the
linking domain view will show the
overall number of referral sessions
received from each domain and the
overall bounce rate the backlink pages
view will show the more detailed data
referal session from each backlink page
and also the bounce rate for each linked
page all right now let's navigate to
backlink profile and then we'll go to
summary So within this module examiner
summary you can like including key
metrics to identify both the strength
and weaknesses of your site now we can
peek at your competitors's backlink
profile also now is the moment to access
your backlink profile in comparison to
your competitors achieving Superior SEO
performance is crucial for securing a
higher ranking than your competitors to
do that go to domain comparison first of
all as you can
see now this is our domain now here
we'll type the competitors's domain
let's like the so the sold
store all right the spelling is wrong
the sold store
is
all right click then there is
Snitch
do.in all
right and one more is there let's
write
mantra.com
all right now let's click
okay so once this process is finished
you'll see a complete comparison of you
and your competitors's domains as we can
see
b.com the sold store snitch.com
now you can easily compare on the basis
of different metrics there are various
metrics over here and as you can see
there is a number
91% in terms of text links domain
strength 9.33 is of mintra and 7.99 of
pof.com and these are for snitch and
these are for soul store.com so you can
easily compare them on the basis of
different metrics all right now coming
to the next step which is spot the
dangerous links before progressing to
actual link building phase it's crucial
to address one final task identify and
remove potential and harmful backlinks
so for that we will go to backlink
profile then the penalty risk so
backlink profile this then we'll go to
penalty
risk all right so this is the penalty
risk it is showing Z % which is a good
thing so basically links with a penalty
risk of 70 to 100% are high risk and
should be checked right away as they
could lead to Google penalizing your
website basically links with a risk of
30 to 70% are potentially harmful so it
is advisible to examine them more
closely then links with the 0 to 30%
penalty risk are considered safe and
posst minimal or no risk in your link
profile all you have to do is to collect
those harmful links and get rid of them
so as you can see there are no penalty
risks so but I need to tell you how to
do that so we'll go to backlink pages
and we'll click on the particular link
as we can see so this button update
penalty risk so it will task updated
backlink page data so it will update the
penalty risk all right so this was about
SE spy glass now let's do the link
building with link
assistant so this link assistant
simplifies your link building tasks it
assists in discovering numerous link
building opport unities managing
Outreach and overseeing your link
building campaign directly within the
app so first of all we'll create a
project and specify the site and
backlink and Target
settings all right so as we can see uh
we can like first of all we'll type
b.com right now so as we have provided
the web address select your desired
Target country so Target country over
here and the Lang language also you can
select from this and other than this the
apps search engine will be tailored
automatically according to your
preferences Additionally you have the
option to include negative keywords in
the top block list so what this is the
app will analyze the backlink profiles
of potential prospects and eliminate
those containing the specified negative
keywords so if you want if you don't
want some negative keywords you can put
it here in the topic block list and that
will not be included all right so this
was it now let's create on I repeat now
let's click on
create all right so this is the layout
now so first by default this will
include the list of top 100 backlinks or
the competitors of your domain with the
highest s link Rank and you can select
any of the six predetermined methods as
we can see six predetermine methods or
the configure customized search this one
configure customized search search using
the expert mode this is the expert mode
basically so these options enable you to
conduct a focused search based on
specific type of Link Prospect you're
seeking if you lack seed keywords you
can utilize the get keyword suggestion
feature this function automatically
identifies your top 20 ranking keywords
that generate the highest
traffic all right so now step two would
be let's say let's explore this one
guest posting top 100 blocks we'll click
on this all right so by employing this
search technique you can identify the
top 100 prospects ranked by organic
traffic using specific search operators
related to your seat keywords to
initiate the search input the seed
keywords here you will write down the
seat keyword so let's say I just want to
write Winter
Wear all right
and you can also do the search engine
settings but I think it is fine
and tags for Future Organization and
management but I don't think I'll be
doing it so after completing the search
first of all we'll have to click on find
so let's click on
this so these are the contact
information this is the page previews
and this is the prospect preview and
additional details are also there you
can select or unselect all the results
to be moved to the prospects like this
right so then we'll click on move to
projects on Hover move any result to
prospects to backlist or to the trash
also so let's just click on this we can
also click on remove Prospect but we are
not going to do that we'll just move two
prospects all right so these are the
prospect that you that we have moved now
that we have possess a recently compile
list of potential links it is crucial to
access their quality and prioritize the
ones we intend to reach out to initially
we'll go to
prospects all right then we'll click on
a URL and update so here is the update
and select contact info so as we can see
contact info we'll click on okay now
that we have settled on the list of
factors you would like to check take
respective data by clicking on the
update button or any of the columns
header take the factors to be updated
like I'll click on uh contact
information and press okay like
that all right can do for this one
also all right so the next step is to
reach out to prospects utilize the app
to initiate Outreach directly taking the
convenience of having all the contact
details at your disposal by connecting
your email account to link assistant you
can centralize and organize your
campaign's correspondence if efficiently
within the application begin reaching
out from the app since you already have
everyone's contact info simply link your
email to link assistant and all your
campaign messages will be saved in one
spot so you can just click on this and
then email so as you can see domain.
operations. atb.com it has taken the
information from contact info and once
you have linked your account or email
then you can it will update over here
and then you can simp simply send it
apply and okay so as you can see dear
owner this I came across your site and
absolutely loved it the thing is I write
my own topics very similar to those so
this is how you can reach and do link
building so that was it for the link
building
part I think SEO powersuit is an
all-in-one toolkit that helps you
improve your online presence easily
enhance your SEO efforts manage your
back links track rankings and more
all-in-one userfriendly package try SEO
powersuit today for a simple and
effective way to supercharge your
website success check the link in the
description box so this was about AI in
marketing now let's understand the next
Trend that is the importance of SE with
the help of Hands-On demo all right next
up we have is YouTube for marketing so
brands are increasingly interested in
utilizing YouTube for their marketing
efforts as YouTube isog as second
largest search platform this means that
people often use YouTube to search for
information entertainment and products
making it a valuable space for Brands to
connect with their target audience
utilizing YouTube can enhance your SEO
boost brand recognition and Foster
customer loyalty YouTube marketing
includes various strategies including
producing authentic promotions content
collaborations with influencers running
advertisements on platform and
optimizing videos for improved SE all
right so this was about YouTube for
marketing now coming to the next one
which is nano influencers so focusing on
Nano influencers who typically have
between 1,000 to 10,000 followers for
Branding is a strategy often employed by
cosmetics and wellness Brands Nano
influencers who have smaller but
dedicated following are often perceived
as more genuine easy to relate and
trustworthy compared to bigger
influencers they can benefit your brand
by boosting engagement expanding your
reach and driving more sales especially
in sectors like cosmetics and wellness
where trust and personal endorsements
matter a lot additionally collaboration
with Nano influencer is more budget
friendly and simpler compared to
partnering with larger influencers or
bigger influencers looking forward to
2024 it's clear that digital marketing
is changing a lot following these new
trends can help businesses connect
better with their customers run
effective campaigns and stay competitive
using AI interactive content and
personalization can set businesses up
for success in the digital world being
flexible and open to change will be
important as these Trends develop all
right guys with that we have come to the
end of this video If you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here